c'est le retour du palmarès des plaintes
de l'Office de la protection du
consommateur du Québec en cinquième
position les concessionnaires de
voitures neuves pour leur créativité
avec les frais légaux
quatrième position les détaillants de
meubles pour les livraisons en retard la
non-conformité des produits et le non
respect de la garantie
troisième position l'industrie de la
construction de l'entretien et de la
rénovation pour le non respect des prix
dans les contrats
deuxième position avec près de 2000
plaintes les électroménagers pour les
problèmes de fiabilité et le chipotage
sur la garantie la plupart des plaintes
vise les grands détaillants d'électro
mais un fabricant se taille une place
dans la liste Whirlpool et maintenant en
première position
[Musique]
industrie de l'automobile d'occasion
en tête de liste depuis une dizaine
d'années entre autres pour des
déclarations trompeuses et l'ajout
illégale de frais au prix annoncé
en terminant soulignons l'entrée
d'Amazon dans le classement par Marc de
commerce entre autres pour la livraison
et la non-conformité des produits avec
147 plaintes
[Musique]